une question de mitsou kissama pourquoi
dit-on d'un homme qu'il est à montjoie
disons le franchement mitsuki c'est une
expression un peu désuète on n'utilise
plus tellement elle désignait à
l'origine un homme qui avait beaucoup de
succès avec les femmes alors pourquoi
donges et bien c'est un personnage que
l'on retrouve dans des dizaines voire
des centaines de pièces de théâtre
d'opéra ou de romans dont les plus
célèbres sont le temps jouant de molière
que beaucoup étudié à l'école don
giovanni de mozart ça c'est pour les
mélomanes mais il ya aussi le poème de
lord byron on le retrouve au cinéma et
même dont des bandes dessinées au départ
au 17e siècle c'est un personnage qui ne
respectent rien ni les rites sociale ni
la morale il a beaucoup de succès avec
les femmes lésiné à s'aimer prison avec
ses anciennes conquêtes au fil du temps
l'image a évolué et aujourd'hui c'est
surtout le côté séducteur qui prend le
dessus